[Music]
so i had to clear our
meeting open any apologies
we'll be finished this part by then
hopefully council brian
um any conflicts of interest
we come to confirmation of
minutes moved by council reckons and
seconded by
council williams uh any
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carriage um item
four uh we come to that four point one
which is selection of projects and
funding arrangements for three water
stimulus
mr cleary
thank you um i'll hopefully be joined by
colin and kelly look this
report i don't intend to go
through all of the projects in detail
but i will give you an overview
of this uh report
um the the purpose of the report is to
gain approval from the council to
effectively lock in the projects that
are to receive the stimulus
funding to sign the funding agreement
and to authorize submission of the
delivery plan so this
as you'll be aware the government
offered as part of
a package to try and stimulate the
economy
following the covert 19
event they have made this money
available
to councils and then they've tied it in
with the signing of the three waters so
you've previously
given authorization to sign the mou
which
effectively unlocked this funding so
um now that
i've outlined the primary purpose of it
this is to get those projects locked in
but it does actually also set us off on
a path
for the next steps of the project and
it's probably worth me talking through
those
just to so the key
the key thing is to try and get a
a effectively agreement in principle in
terms of the project scope so we're
talking about what the projects are
but that actually does include the scope
and the indicative budget for those
projects
um and an example of that is
the step systems for tuahi
and fernside so the scope of the project
in those examples is the proposal to
replace the step system with pressurized
pumps
and that the final details of that will
be subject to consultation so we will
have an opportunity to consult with
those communities
but it's effectively what we're saying
to the government
at this stage in terms of what we're
planning for that
project in terms of the funding
this does again set us on a path of the
general funding principles
we will be bringing a future report to
the council so we'll be giving a
briefing
in october and then following that with
a report intended to come in november
that will talk about the funding
so that council has an opportunity
before putting together the draft long
term plan what that funding
might look like but again we're about
will we need to start consulting with a
community and our first
engagement is going to be points road on
thursday night this week
so again it's it's it's setting a
sending us in a direction to start that
consultation
um now there were also just when we were
socializing with us with the councils
and the council and community boards
there were some requests for extra scope
and
examples of that are putting water mains
in
um out to low burnley and fernside as
par potentially as part of the work
those have yet to be all investigated
and we will investigate those and bring
them back to council
and but it's it is important to note
that
what we're submitting to the government
does not include funding for those
projects so
all the projects we've got um will
use up the entirety of that funding and
so just want to be really clear about
that so in terms of the next steps we'll
be
preparing consultation material and
there's quite a lot to be done in that
space
so we're working with quite a number of
communities across the district on these
projects we're already very busy with
the design and we'll be progressing the
detailed design
and as i talked about earlier we'll be
working to bring a
funding report to you so you can
consider that ahead of the draft
lcp probably the other thing and i
uh just to really just to remind you we
are on quite we have been on a fast
track
since the word go on this and we will
continue to do so right until the
completion of these
uh physical works on these projects
we've got tight
deadlines to meet um and you know the
first one we've got is the having this
signed off and submitted by the end of
the month
but then we've got to get the uh
design complete get the contracts out to
tend to construction underway and get
them complete within the
time frames required by the government
so look i um
i don't think i need to add any more at
this stage
but uh we've got um
colin and i here to answer questions and
also got kelly
and gavin available as well
thank you mr cleary uh first question
after council williams followed by
council duty
hi um endnote h has got
um for the fernside scheme um
will help make contributions of 0.53
million
530 000 um and we've
i understood there was going to be some
consultation with them about
how that was going to be funded
and then i read the a bit further and it
says but there is to be ensuring
there is no increase to their sewer
rates
so what's the point of having
consultation
when it's written here there's going to
be no is that forever
or is there a cutoff date for
um the way it's reading there it says
ensuring there's no increase
to the sewer rates full stop
can that be explained a wee bit please
yes so that that is a note not so you're
not giving approval for that to happen
it's more
noting that that is how the um the
summer
value of work that we can do has been
made to add up so we have this
we've calculated if a fund-side
contribution
on the basis that they would pay a share
of their project and we've looked at
that
from the point of view if they pay the
east and districts rate plus they pay a
contribution
to up to an amount that their wastewater
rates would stay the same
that's the size of contribution that
they would make and it seems like a
sensible starting point
because it's it's some it's proportional
to the amount of work that we would do
on the converting private um wastewater
system
so it's not committing us to that exact
amount and we might consult with them
and that might come up or down a bit um
depending on how that goes but it's
it's a starting point to um for
consultation that that's
that's the sort of figure that would
that um
that makes the total value of projects
add up so it's definitely not a
commitment at this stage what would
happen is we would consult
if something would go in the draft
long-term plan and then
people could submit on it and then that
the size of that contribution could come
up or down depending on that process
so the question is why consult when
originally there was going to have a big
mess of jumps in the
sewer rates and this is why we've done
this and all of a sudden
it cannot be any greater than what
they're paying now so what's the point
of spending a lot of money on
consultation
i think i we haven't actively consulted
with fernside on what we were proposing
so we need to talk to them about it it
doesn't mean
we have to council could decide that
they should make an even greater
contribution if that's what
um is is decided but it so it's
definitely not committing us to that
either way
we just need a starting point to start
the conversation to say that
we have um we've got this proposal um
based on a scheme contribution of this
much and government of this much your
your wastewater rates will stay the same
or and then we could present other
options of greater or lesser than that
to council as well
so i think it's good that from the i
think what you're saying is
it's a no-brainer from the fernside
scheme member's point of view and
hopefully they can see it that way as
well
but we we still need to talk to them
about it yeah so that um
no increase in the
sewer rate is that for ever
uh it's just an indication but yes the
way it's been set up is they pay off a
loan so if you're paying off a loan
then that is quite a well-defined value
and then they would
pay the eastern district rate on top of
that like in 100 years time they'll
never pay any more than what they're
paying today
that's the way it reads okay yeah
i think i take your point we would never
make a guarantee someone's rate would
never change
so we'll be careful in the way we would
that when we
communicate with them
and one another question on jay
uh well hang on sorry not j it is in the
um i j h i
k and l sorry um
for the two heavy water project for the
pressure pump side of um cost of things
um the
if we supply them with um pressure pumps
and they take ownership of them
eventually
will there be an undertaking there that
when they take
ownership of it they will do the
maintenance
on those pumps themself or are we going
to be
stuck with it um doing maintenance and
replacing those pumps when they're due
for a
replacement yeah so certainly the intent
is that will be the case so currently
they own the septic tanks
um that these are replacing and it would
be the intent that that
is their private asset as is the case
for pressure pumps throughout the
district
uh including the likes of pegasus
and beech grove um so this
would fall into that same category and
be in
and be a similar circumstance to what
they're currently so so they'll be
written contract because at the moment
we're still maintaining some of those
pumps here at our council's cost even
though they own them
perhaps just to help council williams at
the end of the
notes it says but the final decisions
regarding funding will be covered by a
later report
my assumption was that that would be
picked up on that further report
perhaps staff could comment on that yes
so that that's a that is a good question
so the
um further report we'll talk about
funding
um and reveals we also have yet to
consult with these communities so this
is the intent
of how we propose to commence that
consultation
but as with any consultation with the
public the council will go and
start staff will sort of taking
direction from elected members
um seeking feedback from the public and
a final position will be
eventually achieved and that'll take
into consideration that
um community feedback as well
as um the council's decision regarding
funding which is yet to e
so this doesn't lock in or commit the
council to
either of those decisions it's just um
at this point it does but it does lock
in this um
as one of the projects
further quick further questions uh
council duty
um just looking at the amount of work
that you've got to do have you got
um and you said you've got some
contractors already
ready to go for all of this have you got
contractors
lined up and that you're going to tap on
the shoulder for later or
how are you going to manage this huge
workload okay yeah that's uh
so in terms of um first firstly in terms
of working managing the workload we are
actually going to deliver the majority
of this work that's in the stimulus
project's in-house
so we have made
a commitment um to in our current
work program to divert project delivery
unit resources on to
make this happen a lot of the designs
already as i said
been underway already so we've got quite
a lot of control
over that we have already set up
the team and or people on board
too so we've got rob kerr as the overall
program manager and we've engaged to
consult
some consultants into that team as well
as
project delivery unit staff we've got
administrative support
coming on stream so we've we've
effectively built the capacity to
deliver it
from a project management program
management and professional services
side um we we will be putting a lot of
pressure on the organization
um with consultation so that will have
uh an impact on our communications team
and across the board uh even you know as
far as the
additional demand on human resources so
and for our finance
section so certainly do acknowledge that
i'm sitting here saying yes we can but
we
are drawing a lot on the capacity of the
organization to do that
so in terms of the actual delivery of
the work some of these projects we can
we can turn on some resource fairly
easily
but they're not they are they um
generally the smaller
parts um without and
but there is a there is a risk with this
we're going to have all of the councils
around the country
but carrying out similar kind of
projects including those around
canterbury so the sooner we can get on
the better we do propose to package the
work in a way that will allow
the contractors who work in our district
to be able to price
and carry out this work um
we would be using the the intention is
for example on the points road water
main to use the water unit as the lead
contractor there they'll need to bring
in
some specialist resources so yeah we're
definitely thinking of
all of those things and actually the
sooner we can get
these out to the market the better place
we're going to be to not only secure the
contractors but
to secure the um the matter
at a good price as well
thanks
thank you mr mayor just following on
from councillor duty's question
um the delivery of our capital works
program
that we endorsed before
before the stimulus package came on
board
when you said you were going to divert
pdu resources are we
still to expect full delivery of our
capital works program which
we didn't deliver sandra could you speak
sorry into the speaker a bit more
because it's
hard to hear yeah i was trying to be
reasonable
sorry he's done a good job but just
adrian can't pick it up here
sorry um i was just following from
councillor duty's question
um that um uh diverting our pdu
resources to make the stimulus package
reality and we've already got a heavy
capital works program which
in pre well previous years even with don
young on board to
manage it we have not been able to
deliver it
so can you give me assurance that we're
we're going to deliver the whole lot
or what's the situation
um i can give you assurance that we're
planning to
deliver the whole lot you know and no no
but when i and i actually
um i i'll just i would just like to draw
your attention to
um one example of a project
that went to the kaiapoi community board
kaipuri community
board last night there um that is one
of the roading package of works
and there is a risk with that project as
an example
where community consultation uh and a
requirement to get an agreement with the
community
to deliver the project um
is is a risk and we have uh
so we've got a package of around about
10 projects in roading um
valued at us you know around about that
around about 10 million dollars
some of those are already underway but
some of them do have similar risks to
the piracy street example
and so i can't give you assurance that
we will deliver all of those
um because there are uh there will be
circumstances that we can control to the
best of our ability
but there will be some circumstances
that do do add a risk to the delivery of
that program um what we but what like
what one of the things we did do in
response to
covet was um we pushed out a lot of work
so from the current financial year that
we're in and to a large extent
this year's capital works program
can be could have prior to the stimulus
work um and the shovel ready work
was basically um dominated by the
roading capital works program which we
wanted to make sure we delivered to meet
our commitment to nzta
our co-funding partner
and also the indoor courts facility
so and that project is well in hand and
underway we
have scaled up to meet this capacity
we've just recruited two
graduate engineers um one of those will
be going straight into
um the this
uh shovel ready and stimulus team
um we as i said we've got consultants in
to
help with it and um we've
uh you know we do so we have actually
done a done recruitment as well to try
and
um give us the capacity to deliver it
we so so we were starting from a much
better position than we did
last year uh in terms of having a more
realistic program to deliver
but you're quite right to highlight it
there is a risk this is a
this is really challenging uh to deliver
such a big
project and the thing that i i
would see is the greatest risk is
rather necessary capacity to do the
design
and the construction it's the ability to
get agreement with each
community that this is what we're doing
and uh get on with that work and then
work through a solution in the
long term plan to agree the funding
arrangement for it
thank you one further question
is um because the stimulus and shovel
really
um package is time has a time constraint
if you're under pressure are you going
to
deliver that and our internal capital
works
get second hit if in fact
things start to get a bit frayed around
the edges
um short answer to that is yes
yes and that is the case we are taking
that approach with our roading capital
works
to an extent um and
these uh so
these projects um would take
priority on resources um although what
i'm
uh but we are in a position where we do
believe we've got a
um a type but we do it is tight but we
do think we've matched the resources to
the
size of the project in front of us i'll
just give you the the
shovel ready um effectively the design
work for that
is going to be done by consultants
because we just don't have the
uh capacity in the house to deliver that
so it's sometimes it's more about where
do we allocate the work to be done
rather than necessarily whether we give
one priority or over the other
um if we had a much longer time horizon
we might be able to do some of that more
in-house
but rather in this case where
we've made a very early decision that we
need to get
those pump station pipeline designs
carried out externally
quarterly to audition risk or are you
going to make it monthly
to what utilities and writing or
auditing
on this project
um we will be presenting a uh
a program to the council in terms of
reporting it will be
um we we we're effectively intending
that we would be reporting to the
council or the utilities and writing
committee every month
we're going to have um crown record
reporting requirements
um in the case of shove already that's
actually a fortnightly
report so it's a big part of this and
we're
so we're expecting that we'll be giving
you a steady stream of reporting
predominantly to the council to the
utilities and writing committee
on these projects and when it comes to
the shovel really that would also
include the kaipoi touri community
board thanks jared um council barnett
yes thank you jared um you've mentioned
that you recruited engineers and
and obviously there was a drain weighs a
little waterways manager position in
there
and you've also mentioned that
consultation is probably one of the
biggest risks
in this project with the fact that that
our com staff are really stretched with
long-term plan district
plan consultation does this budget also
include
further employment of consultation and
communication stuff
it's probably a german question
we haven't got a specific allocation and
would you like jim to here
so short answer is yes the project
management of each of that program of
work is going to need to include a
provision for comms
that at the moment we're just recruiting
for a role
uh for comms and engagement which has
three elements to it district plan
regeneration and a starting resource
so a starting resource for the
additional 28 million of
program of works that is sitting here so
that has a fixed term components it's a
two-year fixed term role
and if we need to then go to more
engagement or com support particularly
for the shovel ready
and stimulus package program of works
then
then we'll do that and that will need to
be funded from the project
management component of this program of
work
okay i think we've had a good range of
questions here so i'm going to move from
the chair 4.1
or the recommendation seconded by
council williams
council williams already indicated to me
so uh second to counselor williams
um just speaking to it
uh just to say i think our staff have
done
a superb job in this space we there's
there's been some questions here today
but not probably from all of us because
of
all the homework you've done in advance
of this i want to say how proud i am of
jared you and your team
colin kelly and gavin that are here the
extraordinary amount of work you've put
in a short space of time to get
us to a position where you've found a
fair
and equitable way of allocating this as
best as you can
and the way in which you've led us
through this period also want to
acknowledge
jim as well um uh some of you might know
but jim's
jim's been doing an extraordinary amount
of work here that canterbury mural forum
uh level as well um unpicking all this
and making
and getting it to a point so we can
understand it and get it into a
framework that means as a canterbury
area we've
we can consider broader options which
are part of this exercise which we're
not getting into today necessarily but
i look you guys have done a fantastic
job you've
thought of all the issues you've brought
in consultant needs and particularly
someone to help in the project
management
of this which i thought was really smart
trying to get ahead of it because there
is an enormous amount of work
and we are going to have to be team
really understanding of our staff
and the level of work that we've got on
their shoulders
we're buying into this as much as they
are
putting this work out for us so when it
comes to
keeping to time frames and reporting and
all the rest there needs to be a level
of understanding
because our community would not thank us
for not accepting this so
i just want to put that on the record
that yes we all want to make sure the
reporting and standards are met
as best as possible but there has to be
a degree of understanding
if we're to um achieve this uh and get
this work
undertaken looking forward to the
engagement on
thursday with um points road hopefully
it's a more positive
conversation than the last one but um
we you know i i think you've done the
best that you can to put forward
a really good um proposal for us here so
thank you
on behalf of the council thank you very
much that was endorsed by the community
boards last week
who also shared that view to your
council williams yeah i think it's a
great project um and it's good stimulus
for the whole of waimakariri and i think
we've
just got to make sure we're economical
the way we're doing thing
and think of the whole of the
waimakariri community
while we're doing this funding and just
don't pick on
certain targets in the area and which
could mean some of the
rest of our community can miss out on a
bit of stimulus so it's a
stimulus package which we're going to
get
some major things across the line which
normally would have been
very very hard if near impossible to get
across the line
so we've got to be thinking of the whole
of waimakariri while we're doing it
and be quite economical and don't waste
our stimulus
package council stuart
thank you mr samir um i certainly
endorse um
your comments about um this very very
impressive
piece of work so congratulations to you
all
and i just take the point that the mayor
has just said about understanding
um the um the extent of the work
that we are all committing ourselves for
when we need to know if it is not going
well or as well as expected and that is
what i mean about reporting
that's to bring it back so that we do
understand whether
it's it's going well or our and even
more importantly if it's not going well
because then we will need to be able to
think about how things may be reject or
whatever so
the reporting to my mind talks about
all that and we need to be right up to
speed with the difficulties or
the um the good things that you're
achieving
so welcome the reporter thank you
for the speakers council
yes i'm really really comfortable with
the work that's been done on
this project and it's a huge opportunity
for us
to fix some of the historic issues that
we've carried through in infrastructure
and it benefits residents as other
colleagues have mentioned it across our
whole district and
the risk that i mentioned about the
consultation which is obviously
it's really really important that we
have to bring the community along with
us
in what we're doing we're going to need
open
very transparent conversations to keep
to our timelines
and very very clear messaging so i would
like to make sure that there is
a lot of resource available in that
space
we also need as a council to support our
staff to keep an open mind if the
situation changes
which it can do but keep our goal in
mind
and and take the opportunity take this
funding
which benefits our whole district
thank you for the speakers councilwool
thank you well done and i know that
you're going to
get this through in the next couple of
years and do it really really well with
the support of everyone
including us and the community boards
to make decisions in a timely fashion so
that you can proceed
and get the job done one of the things i
think when you're consulting with
the likes of points road or tohiwi or
wherever
um you know i've always found that you
can't please
everybody all of the time and so um
take into consideration that as long as
you know that what
we're doing is right um then just get on
with the job
thank you thank you councillor duty
thank you yeah just a rhetoric
congratulations and well done
for you all the work you've put in the
whole lot of you and that
gym included on this one it's just such
a huge
task that you've been given to do
and and you're going to be managing it
by the look of it very well
and be interested to see how we go on
thursday night
and that'll be our first teething
opportunity won't it
thank you further speakers
okay nothing to respond to so i'm going
to put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary declare that thanks team
all right so um
item five is no longer required so
we now move to um
item six point so we've firstly we need
to move
to public excluded moved by council
atkinson seconded by council blacky
we're now in public excluded can we just
check the live streams off
thank you
[Music]